we're delighted to today to be able to
tell
gitane go Kenya's most prominent
activist and CEO of in Kuen ECC an NGO
that works on citizen empowerment and
good governance as the speaker for the
coca-cola world fund lecture at Yale the
coca-cola lecture was established in
1992 by Roberto gazeta former chair and
CEO of coca-cola and yell alumnus class
of nineteen fifty-three to support the
intersecting endeavors among specialists
in international relations international
law and the management of international
enterprises and organizations mr.
Gaetano is also chair of the Africa
Institute for governing with integrity
he's a board member of the Africa Center
for open governance and a commissioner
for the Independent Commission on aid
impact of the British government for the
British government it from 2003 to 2004
mr. Gaetano served as permanent
secretary for governance and ethics in
the post transition government of
Kenya's third president my kibaki
however he began to expose corruption
within the administration that appointed
him a rare act of courage and which
necessitated he's eventually having to
leave the country and he spent some time
in Britain but he returned to Kenya in
2008 his story is told in Michaela
warn't wrong spoke it's our turn to eat
in 2011 mr. gitonga was selected at one
of the most 100 most influential
Africans by new African magazine and one
of the world's top 100 global thinkers
by foreign policy magazine he's also
being worked as a correspondent for The
Economist magazine the title his toes
and for today's lecture is corruption
security and development volatile nexus
I'm pleased to introduce John gitonga
good afternoon everyone thank you very
much professor Shapiro for that kind
introduction I should like to start by
thanking Yale University and the
macmillan center for international area
studies for inviting me to deliver this
coca-cola world fund lecture and
welcoming me to this wonderful city of
New Haven and Yale University which I
have only read about and heard about and
The Sun has actually been shining the
last two days I've been here I'll share
some insights on corruption and security
on democracy and development insecurity
corruption and development and the
challenge that inequality poses to us
now and then identity-based politics in
today's world and how resilient it has
proved and then I'll look up and fought
I always like to end with a positive
note despite the fact that well we have
to admit that to 2014 was a terrible
year for security and development with
the specter of conflict in Middle East
Africa and even the former Soviet Union
your rearing its ugly ugly head the past
two days for me have been spent in the
morning feeling telephone calls from
colleagues in Europe and and back in
Kenya about what they call him the Swiss
leaks scandal these bank accounts at
HSBC that have been made public by a
crusading media organization but it for
me tells an important story about
corruption I've had the privilege of
being involved with transparency
international since its foundation Peter
I ghen who
founding chairman of transparencies
national was the head of the World Bank
in Kenya and I met him when I was still
in high school and you're a good friend
of my father's I was very skeptical very
skeptical about an NGO fighting
corruption even though I ended up
becoming the first executive director of
transparency international in Kenya but
the whole Swiss leaks issue has reminded
me about a reform ization of of crack of
corruption since the early 2000s after a
period of what are called in
formalization because of the activism
that we saw in the 1990s when
transparencies Nationals started and the
groups like the world bank and the G
wolfensohn made corruption a key issue
in the global development agenda and so
some of the progress that we've made has
been been drawn back secondly and
touching on corruption and security we
have a quiet joke when I was in
government of the government for two
years that's over over two years and
that in Africa we shall fight to the
last Nigeria because it's Africa's most
populous country most powerful country
richest country and the Nigerians are
the most robust confident people and the
Nigerian military for its call its
weaknesses but has been essential to
intervening in some of the worst crisis
is that we've had in west africa over
the past two decades and yet over the
last one and a half years it has been
alarming for all of us who watch these
issues to see the nigerian army at some
points fleeing in the face of a group
like Boko Haram and that has been
challenging to us just recently in the
last forty forty eight twenty two hours
the military has announced that they
cannot guarantee security for the
elections so the electrons have been
postponed until the end end of March
which brings us to to to Kenya as well
where we are faced with a unique
challenge the Kenya army went into
Somalia in late 2011 against the Horn of
Africa as al-qaida affiliate this was
called al-shabaab and the blowback
subsequently has exposed some of our
pressing governance challenges and at
the heart of those we have 4,000 troops
in Somalia is how corruption and the
mines the ability of our security sector
sector to prosecute its core mandate
something which especially the middle
class had always taken for granted that
if your middle class you'll be protected
by the police and by the arm but here
they're confronted by a group that is
able to undermine that we've also
learned an important lesson about these
these groups a group like al-shabab and
the extraordinary capacity to reinvent
themselves to evolve and transform
themselves and that they
organizationally designed to change
according to the changing contexts which
makes them deeply resilient the other
insight that we we have learned when
these groups are confronted especially
by a corrupt opponent is that they're
not actually trying to win al-shabaab is
not trying to win anything in in Kenya
in the conventional sense they aim to
survive to subvert and turn to undermine
the essential edifice to which they are
inherently opposed this realization has
changed the language used in their
regard so there is no longer talk of
victory or success against what is
essentially an idea that seems have gone
wild they talk of the degradation of the
capacity to age there are they are
degrading the capacity I'll talk about
what when what does victory me
against these groups especially when
they're confronted by states whose
capacity is undermined by corruption let
me focus a little more on that on on
corruption and the lessons from al-qaeda
stroke al-shabaab in Kenya which are
very poignant to to us in Kenya as I
said one of the lessons as has been that
corruption rots all institutions when
when it's in us in a society when he
becomes systemic and pervasive and when
it grips the security services then we
see the kind of things that we're seeing
in Nigeria and we know we caught a
glimpse of in Kenya much to our alarm
before the Kenyan army invaded somalia
to to to deal with arch above quote
unquote a Shabaab and about eight
hundred thousand dollars a year from the
port of kismayo revenues earned mainly
from taxing goods that were being
smuggled into Kenya like sugar and other
things between 20 and 40 thousand metric
tons of sugar was coming in through his
mind to kenya by late-2012 four million
sacks of charcoal worth 60 million u.s.
dollars was sitting quayside in Kismayo
and the King army had successfully
together with the support of Amazon
troops from other African countries
taken control of of that port from
al-shabaab from November that's a mere
the unfortunately and this is being the
price of corruption own kenya defence
forces and our allies started allowing
exports out of the port in 2013 1
million sacks of charcoal left the port
every month the trade was handled
by 40 al-shabaab affiliated traders
between july 2013 and may 2014 it's
estimated that 6.7 to go up 6.8 million
bags of charcoal exported out of k smile
to the extent that by last year the UN
concluded the tire Shabaab continues to
benefit from revenue generated on a
scale greater than when it controlled k
smile the revenues would split three
ways between al-shabaab an outfit that
some of you may have heard of quadratic
Ambani it has always been fairly strong
in that part part of somalia these are
the forces who ran actually the port and
the kenyan business interests
facilitated by our own military so the
invasion has made al-shabaab rich and
they are able to fight us yeah in kenya
over 100 attacks since november 2011
we've had over 100 attacks by in with in
kenya something that is completely you
know i wouldn't say we're not accustomed
to it because we have the 1998 al Qaeda
attack at the US embassy in Nairobi and
also the US Embassy in dar Salam so al
Qaeda has been around us for some time
but we've always felt on top of it over
the past two years these attacks have
shaken our own confidence in our in our
security services because they've been
so many culminating in one in September
2013 that saw one of the most
prestigious more than narrow be the
Westgate Mall attack by a small group of
terrorists and 67 people killed and over
100 injured in all of the fiasco for our
security services our response has not
has also not helped since 2012 21 Muslim
clerics have been assassinated and an
operation to flush out terrorists from
Nairobi in a
1 2014 was carried out in a manner that
further alienated the Muslim community
in the Somali community in particular
because the raids were accompanied by
reports of bribes corruption rape in as
as 0 carried out so corruption has
helped fuel radicalism and
radicalization of our you as we have
responded to the problem so with every
response we seem sometimes to make the
problem worse corruption we've always
said is carried out by embedded networks
particular in countries where it is
systemic and pervasive these networks
include of necessity for four groups of
players you have the politicians who
give the cover you have the bureaucrats
who push the paper from one office to
the next you have the the private sector
which includes usually briefcase
businessmen who just have an account in
the Cayman Islands and a briefcase and
I'm moving together with with the
politicians and bureaucrats and the
security sector you always need somebody
in the military or intelligence services
for our grand corruption scheme to
happen in many third world countries one
of the important realizations that we've
made over the past decade and a half is
the critical role to the architecture of
corruption of the service sector the
global banks and international legal
firms and you are talking about legal
firms that are able to operate in
multiple jurisdictions at the same time
so icons action may be initiated in
Kenya but the payments are made in
Mauritius and the money goes to
Switzerland then to British version
Islands and then back to Nairobi through
client accounts and the role of these
the banks the legal sector the telecom
companies real estate mortgage firms are
essential to the grand corruption that
we are seeing today the financial crisis
that we saw here in the West in 2008
revealed a deeper malaise and I think
this is not something that is a negative
in the long run that in the fight
against corruption there are those who
are sometimes too big to fail or too big
to jail and they take expose the outer
limit of what's possible using the tools
of the rule of law to tackle corruption
in contexts where entire financial and
political systems in the grip of a
particular way of doing things I often
challenged my colleagues when we talk
about corruption in Africa that I'm
still waiting to see because the message
that is brought to us when I was in
government I was always being pushed by
diplomats and World Bank IMF you must
fry the big fish until you find the big
fish you're not fighting corruption
until we see a politician in court but
senior civil servant in court you're not
fighting corruption and I can now say
well it seems to be difficult to fry the
big fish here as well and so it's a it's
a global issue that we need to address
together now I'll make I'll speak to
that near near the end one of one of the
responses to this and driven also by
digital technology plus I younger
generation that is a lot more skeptical
about politics politicians political
parties
is an unregulated kind of social
sanction sanction that has kicked in
till you have WikiLeaks you have mr.
Edward Snowden and a host of other
manifestations of people blowing the
whistle and putting information into the
public domain in a way that is would not
have been possible or what have happened
20 or 25 years ago so this is this is
the reality that we are living in it and
this is for me I see the younger
generation which is the majority that it
has this sense of exhaustion that pushes
this very very strongly my second
overall point is to do with democracy
and development the after the fall of
the Berlin Wall democracy scepter across
the former Soviet Union across the
African continent but now today is
challenged by other models we have seen
rapid economic growth without this kind
of multiparty democracy is that we've
adopted in parts of Africa in China for
example and so this the model has some
appeal especially to those of our
leaders who are more or for Italian
leaning this is a fairly attractive
model and it has made a difference
however I know we acknowledged it to the
Chinese model we're talking about a
highly organized state when one does the
research the Chinese weather had had a
state as long as 1800 years ago so it's
it's it has very deep cultural roots but
still we are coming to terms with the
fact that while we've adopted
multi-party politics with all its
institutions and rules and regulations
liberal democracy is not going to result
in
part of the third world it's not going
to happen okay are not going to become
Norway or Sweden so what it going to
become and we're in the process of
defining that now the process is
extremely messy because we've gone into
state building in some cases before
nation building where you don't have a
sense of collective nationhood in places
where a state with its institutions are
already being crafted I said the process
is messy and so sometimes some of the
violence that we see around the world in
my opinion can be seen as states
collapsing or nation-building taking
place as bored as our are torn down
secondly the liberal democracies that we
have adopted the economic model that
comes with them has delivered growth
sometimes without development and often
growth without equity and it's a
challenge here in the West as well where
inequality has become the challenge of
the age and inequality means a
concentration of power and a
concentration of power no matter how
graceful or delicate did no matter how
gracefully are delicately executed means
corruption it necessarily discriminates
against the young the women the less
educated minorities and the poor
generally thirdly I'll go back to this
nexus between security corruption and
development and this unraveling that we
are seeing where we seem to be going
back to a poor posture now to argue that
this is partly as a result of the
resilience of identity politics
large parts of the world week we had
thought would be undermined by countries
adopting multiparty democracy and
liberal democracy and it's and politics
generally the Cold War was clear and
stuck in its definitions and the Berlin
Wall fell and we saw a flourishing of
democracy freedom house and other such
organizations argue that we've been in
the middle of a democratic recession
since 2006 one thing that seems to have
happened and this is drawn very much for
my own African experience of
democratization since the early 1990s is
that more and more regimes and this
pluralistic era have lost a monopoly of
violence and we've seen a gradual
erosion or deterioration of legitimate
authority of all governments leaders and
political parties and this is not only
hibited traffic about across the world
and so I've heard read research that
actually governments I think professor
most name describes it governments are
more Italian they last shorter more
coalition's overwhelming victories are
rare you know you don't have landslide
victories anymore you have close
victories highly contested elections and
those administration's last a short time
and the politicians are mistrusted
especially by the users don't trust or
believe in them I should like to work at
least from where where we stand is that
identity based formations have taken
away the states monopoly of violence and
in a sense this is partly what groups
like it's like Islamic state al-qaeda
etc and then what's what we are watching
happening in parts of Africa like the
Central African Republic majare malli
it's also done is happening is a
regressive identity-based of hurricanes
and it's responded to asymmetrically
because it reads elections it controls
the media it discombobulates civil
society and represented in the
international war against terror by the
IED was the drone nonnamous WikiLeaks
this leagues that I've already mentioned
before and our convergence between
commercial and political interests at a
time the private sector is consolidating
its hold on on public policy so this
legitimate authority of all the
institutions of governance has been
ground down and eroded over over time
one can ask a question how come or even
authoritarian regimes are unable to keep
a lid on identity based security
challenges and it's often because they
themselves mobilize along identity lines
especially in this post quote-unquote
post ideological phase even if they
pretend otherwise and so you know I have
been very struck by what's been
happening in in the in the former Soviet
Union in Russia in particular and
Ukraine recently where there is this
sort of nationalistic of surge that is
that is developing there and I I don't
think it is something that is limited to
that part of the world at all so we live
in a volatile time where the nations and
state that we are going to forge will
need to take these the resilience of
some of these factors into account so
I'd like to to look forward and look up
going forward and one fundamental
reality in that this I'll take very much
from the Kenyan context that the
research that is done by a group like
afro barometer every every few years
that that does opinion polls across
African continent in terms of what
Africans believe and feel about their
democracy and one of the important
things this
the Democratic roll back that we are
seeing in many countries people remain
committed to democracy as a model I
think it was church you said it's it's
the it's a worst form of government
except all others people remain very
committed to democracy and to the
freedoms that they have won freedom of
association of speech partly because
they can remember what it was like not
to have those freedoms and when you can
remember in your parents can remember it
gives you tremendous incentive to load
it secondly the other modules aren't
that attractive no matter how powerful
and how much attention how much
batteries are taking up not i'm not even
hurt my Muslim friends talking about
wanting to live and in the Caliphate of
mr. Alba daddy the other models are not
that compelling and so it makes sense
that this regardless of how messy
democracy is it remains the system of
governing ourselves that people remain
very very committed to secondly it may
do and this is something that the UN
United Nations level two points the
united nations convention against
corruption was ratified in 2003 it's
been about 12 13 years now I think it's
time for a review of the of its
implementation around the world given
what we are seeing and the fact that
corruption is back stronger than ever
and around the world now when you have
the kind of schedules but only the third
work but in the first it's good because
now we can look each other in the face
and and and say that you know we have
difficulties in Africa but here in
America to you have candidates let's
discuss them as equals and honestly so
let's review what how serious the
the the provisions of the united nations
convention against corruption are after
all this time if corruption has wasn't
as transparent its national others
showing there in the indexes secondary
the Millennium Development Goals and
this is something that I've been
plugging they didn't expire but the
15-year run came to an end in December
and committee has been formed at the UN
to come up with new Global Development
Goals i think that started it worked
last month there were big meetings at
the UN in September and december and so
we've been advocating to get more
accountability and anti-corruption
provisions in in the next round of
development goals and it's an
opportunity to to lobby for that thirdly
and this was initially a g7 initiative
last year pushed very much by Britain
and the United States of creating a
register of beneficial ownership of
cooperations especially in the tax
havens transparent in in those tax
havens we need that more than ever
before because the ability to hide to
hide money is hinges very heavily on the
ability on the secrecy around these tax
havens and the truth of the matter is
this I talked about the embedded
corruption networks they have globalized
two and one of the things that we have
found in our part of the world when we
look at the drug trade when we look at
environmental corruption which is
hitting us very hard which is the trade
in ivory rhino horns you know plants and
and the like when one looks at people
trafficking slavery it is
now more profitable for organized crime
to be involved in the trafficking of it
slavery of girls than trading in Harry
money laundering the laundering of
corruption proceeds all the networks
that I used especially in the service
sector are the same for all of them it's
usually the same banks in the 1990s the
movement of terror terrorism financed
finances in in our part of the world
used for its bureaus hawala systems etc
partly because of external pressure i
know the internal pressure this has this
has gone down and to our surprise said
it's been reform alized it's gone back
into the formal system so you you will
drive a lab in for number of cities in
many parts of the world where you you'll
see car showrooms with very high-end
vehicles suvs several million dollars of
them that aren't selling past there week
after week is the same vehicles are
there and that's in that in that
jurisdiction as a legitimate company
with a legitimate legitimate bank
account with a lawyer's managing their
affairs and so we've had a reform
ization of the illicit resources that
are managed by these networks globally
so i asked the question and i often get
in trouble for this i have we reached do
we need a corruption transitional
justice cutoff point and i'll explain
what i mean by that after the end of
apartheid in south africa
it was recognized that they had to be
some closure with this horrible history
that South Africa had to be able to move
forward with some confidence now the
compromises and that have to be made in
that kind of process are always
contentions and I believe if they're not
contentious then it's not work you can't
have one side that emerges out of that
kind of process very happy everybody has
to reignite a bit happy in a bit unhappy
these tools that are used in a human
right arena could some of them be used
via via corruption to introduce
transparency especially in this era of
too big to fail too big to jail too big
to fry where we can introduce an
international regime of transparency
accompanied with aggressive disclosure
at the global UN level with with
oversight regarding financial flows
complete with an international
anti-corruption traditional instrument
to deal with these these massive flows
that we've now recognized you know
overlap from terrorism to drugs to
people trafficking is it time to start
discussing the creation of such
instruments at the UN level to add on to
you know spoons up the united nations
convention against corruption faithfully
fifthly is the issue of campaign finance
and logging has a time come for us to
accept that the relationships that come
with lobbying and campaign finance are
so fraught with potential potentialities
for corruption and a potentially so
decided I disadvantages to minorities
and the poor that
States finance parties as much as
possible and i'll leave that there but
political party finance has been
something that I've been grappling with
for the last 20 years no one has really
given me a model that works very well
the only places i've seen we are
interesting attempts is where you have
state finance of political parties and
you don't have a disproportionate introd
power bi bi bi private interests last
but not least in the war against terror
i think one of the big lessons that I
want to talk very much the Kenyan
perspective is that we realized that it
will be worn by Muslims and by our
Muslims in our own context in our own
society and and there is not a way of
going about it said with ash about the
lesson that surprised us that when you
talk to their sympathizers the smoky
when you win what does that victory look
like it doesn't there's no there's no
answer to that and they are pleased that
they're confronted by a corrupt opponent
on the other side that being the case we
realized that for it to be dealt with in
a manner that is conclusive it is our
own Muslim community that is part of our
society that has the answers to these
questions but they need to be put in a
manner I heard it did you know when when
you see all the problems as a nail then
you use a hammer hit them all and
perhaps trying to put down the hammer
sometimes when dealing with these issues
finally and this is drawn very much from
the experience of Eastern Africa as we
deal with these developmental and
security contradiction
we've come to an aspirational conclusion
with colleagues and we discusses that we
have borders across a continent in 54
countries that were drawn up by the
colonial powers and actually we will not
have peace and security and until some
of those borders come down disappear
that regional integration economic
political and social is an imperative
for the survival of certain countries
some countries are simply not viable
economically or politically and back
breakdown needs to happen sooner rather
than later and the process has already
started their mission has been made but
vested interests continue to hold out
but the agency has been raised by the
fact that we are confronted now we
bought our described as a world class
enemy al Qaeda has given the u.s. so
much trouble you can expect that it will
give us it's giving us a lot of trouble
in Kenyan the Horn of Africa as well
finally and this is a niche which I
always raised very tentatively because
in turn in my anti-corruption circles
I've always objected to the idea that
corruption has a cultural aspect to it
and because I all is very very
suspicious when people talk of
corruption and culture they say some
cultures are more corrupt than others
and I feel that you know there's a
racial thing going on that's a no no
noit's it's the same everywhere but I
spent some time in South Sudan advising
the government about 23 years ago and
sitting with the elders from the new air
and tinker communities they told me no
you know languages we don't have a word
for
we have only got a word for theft we
know a thief and in fact a thief the
family the thief cannot get married
across the valley that we understand and
I'll close there I mean that's for me
has been a humbling lesson taught to me
by elders in the countryside in South
Sudan we've been talking about the fight
against corruption good government
transparency accountability all these
nice words we learned after the fall of
the Berlin Wall and when I went into the
countryside in outside Juba it's the old
men who told me this corruption thing
really what is it but it somebody steals
my cows that's a thief and he cannot be
allowed to go into government he cannot
marry my daughter I'll leave it there
and open it up to two questions thank
you very much for